it's a Witch Hunt it's free speech it's
political activity won't someone please
think of the First Amendment special
prosecutor Jack Smith has indicted
Donald Trump in Washington DC for
conspiracy to subvert the presidential
election results and Trump is
predictably not too happy about it he
twitted out on Truth social if you go
after me I'm coming after you in
response to the doj filed a motion for
protective order that would prevent
Trump from disclosing Discovery
materials to the public now Trump says
this motion was actually a blanket gag
order that would prohibit him from
exercising his free speech and a hearing
was held on August 11th now in addition
to all the motion practices happening
before trial Trump and his lawyers say
that everything that Trump said in the
run-up to January 6 is protected
political speech and therefore can't be
the basis of criminal charges now Trump
has had a lot of things in the context
of January 6th does he actually have a
First Amendment Free Speech defense well
to start with speech is generally
protected under the First Amendment
unless it falls within one of the few
categories of unprotected speech now
we'll get into those categories in a few
minutes because when you're trying
talking about Trump those categories
actually come up with quite a bit of
frequency but first let's talk about why
Trump says his words and actions are
protected speech the Supreme Court
considers political and ideological
speech to be at the core of the First
Amendment including speech concerning
quote politics nationalism religion or
other matters of opinion now Trump says
that he's being persecuted for political
speech in the indictment the prosecutors
accused him of communicating with other
people in an attempt to overturn the
election and here's how the alleged
conspiracies worked before the general
election the political parties from each
state chose their own potential
Electoral College electors after the
votes are in each state prepares their
certificates of ascertainment that are
authenticated with a government
signature and the indictment accuses
Trump and his allies of conspiring to
prepare fake certificates in seven
states that Trump lost Arizona Georgia
Michigan Nevada New Mexico Pennsylvania
and Wisconsin and Trump's plan dependent
on vice president Mike Pence using those
certificates to block or delay Congress
from recognizing Biden's Victory now
Trump's lawyer John lauro told CNN that
quote this is an attack on free speech
and political advocacy and there's
nothing that's more protected under the
First Amendment than political speech
now I agree with lauro that Trump
generally has a right to lie about the
election results forever if he wants to
however Laurel goes even further than
that saying that Trump had a free speech
right to ask Pence and others to take
action on his behalf lauro often
defended Trump by claiming that his
extra legal demands were aspirational
that was an asper hold on one second
that was an aspirational ask now Trump
claims that there's no harm in just
asking Pence to do something that might
hypothetically break the law or at least
be against the law lauro says that the
Biden Administration has criminalized
the free speech of Prior Administration
and that it is particularly egregious
because it's happening while there is a
political election happening to trump it
looks like the government is trying to
stop him from expressing his political
opinions now Trump's Defenders use the
same defense during his second Senate
impeachment trial the house January 6
committee recommended that Trump be
charged with violating these seditious
conspiracy statute because of the speech
he gave to the protesters at the ellipse
the seditious conspiracy law 18 USC 2383
and 2384 make it a crime when someone
quote incites sets on foot or engages in
any Rebellion or Insurrection against
the authority of the United States now
historically the government has used
sedition charges to shut down political
dissent especially during times of war
and Trump is right that we don't want
the government to persecute people
because of their political speech that's
why today it's extremely hard to convict
someone of inciting violence based on
their opinions we've covered incitement
law a bunch of times on this channel
it's very difficult to prove under the
Brandenburg test and although the First
Amendment does not protect speech that
incites imminent Lawless action it does
protect speech that Advocates
overthrowing the government in abstract
terms whether the speech really does
incite imminent Lawless action is a hard
nut to crack which is probably why
special prosecutor Jack Smith did not
charge Trump with seditious conspiracy
most people think that he probably did
this to avoid Trump's First Amendment
defense but Smith still used Trump's
words as evidence that he committed
other crimes now is he allowed to do
that well the government anticipated
that Trump would make the case about
free speech so the indictment Begins by
making the distinction between First
Amendment and Criminal Honda quote the
defendant had a right like every
American to speak publicly about the
election and even to claim falsely that
there had been outcome determinative
fraud during the election and that he
won he was also entitled to formally
challenge the results of the election
through lawful and appropriate means
such as by seeking recounts or audits of
the popular vote in states or filing
lawsuits challenging ballots and
procedures now this is the justice
department so you are allowed to take
their statements of FLT to the First
Amendment with a grain of salt but Trump
lost the lawsuits that he filed and the
indictment says that Trump tried to
overturn the election by illegal means
quote shortly after election day the
defendant also pursued unlawful means of
discounting legitimate votes and
subverting the election results now this
is the heart of the disagreement between
the Trump and the Department of Justice
Trump world's argument boils down to the
idea that words can't be crimes and that
definitely misunderstands the issue in
most of criminal law as former Trump
attorney general Bill Barr explains you
know as the indictment says you know he
he they're not attacking his first
amendment right he can say whatever he
wants he can even lie he can even tell
people that that the the election was
was stolen when he when he knew better
but uh that does not protect you from
entering into a conspiracy all
conspiracies involve speech and all
fraud involves speech now Bart is saying
that there's no first amendment
protection for speech made in service of
a crime so let's talk about that now not
all speech is protected by the First
Amendment for example defamatory
statements are not protected now Trump
knows this because for some reason he's
always saying he wants to make it easier
for people to sue for defamation and you
know he does actually file a fair number
of defamation lawsuits and earlier this
year he lost a defamation case after e
Gene Carroll sued him for claiming that
he did not rape her and on the other
side of the coin Trump has actually won
defamation suits against people like
Stormy Daniels and was successfully able
to file an anti-slap motion against her
now false statements may form the basis
of other legally cognizable harm such as
fraud false advertising or perjury and
Trump has been sued for fraud before in
2016 he's settled a lawsuit which
alleged that Trump University made false
claims about being affiliated with
accredited universities lied about Trump
hand-picking instructors and lied about
passing on valuable real estate Secrets
now that kind of commercial speech has
fewer First Amendment protections when
someone makes false statements and if
the government can prove it has a
substantial interest in making sure
consumers aren't deceived it can
regulate certain types of commercial
speech and on top of that things that
qualify as speech often constitute what
are called Legal acts think about it
speech is often how we accomplish stuff
we tell people what we want and what we
want them to do and generally the First
Amendment doesn't protect speech quote
used as an integral part of conduct and
violation of a valid criminal statute
now this is why the government is
allowed to prohibit solicitation to
commit a crime or conspiracy to commit a
crime or impersonating a government
officer in each of these crimes it
involves speech but a prosecutor can use
a person's words as evidence that they
committed that crime for example if a
bank robber demands that a bank teller
hand over the money the statements
aren't protected speech those words form
the basis of the crime that's being
committed and under Trump's
interpretation of the First Amendment
the bank robber could argue that when he
gave the teller a note demanding money
it was merely a suggestion aspirational
to use lauro's words and if we accept
Trump's Free Speech argument it's hard
to see how it would ever be legal for
the government to punish perjury which
punishes a person for lying under oath
and other crimes like knowingly making a
false statement to law enforcement in
violation of 18 USC 1001 would also be
off the books and unfortunately for
Trump soliciting another individual to
commit a crime is not protected by the
First Amendment for example in the
United States versus Williams the
Supreme Court considered whether the
protect act Abridged First Amendment
freedom of speech by outlawing the
pandering of material that is believed
to be child pornography Justice Scalia
writing for the majority included the
quote offers to engage in illegal
transactions are categorically excluded
for first amendment protection the court
observed the quote to be sure there
remains an important distinction between
a proposal to engage in illegal activity
and the abstract advocacy of illegality
Scalia concluded that the protect Act
was not overbroad because it quote does
not prohibit advocacy of child
pornography but only offers to provide
or request to obtain it the opinion goes
on to say the quote many
long-established criminal prosecutions
such as laws against conspiracy
incitement and solicitation criminalized
speech commercial or not that is
intended to induce or commence illegal
activities and in other cases on point
is the 1915 case of United States versus
Mosley that dealt with a conspiracy by
two Oklahoma County election board
officials to Omit certain legal votes
from the official count the men were
charged with conspiracy under 18 USC 241
which is one of the statutes that Trump
allegedly violated and in that case the
court observed that although 241 was
enacted to stop the Ku Klux Klan quote
the statute dealt at the time with all
federal rights of all citizens and
protected them all and still continues
to do so the county officials engaged in
multiple conspiracies first they agree
not to count certain votes second they
met in secret without the knowledge of
the third member of the Board of
Elections for the purpose of carrying
out the conspiracy and third they
committed overt acts towards achieving
their goals the two men met and used
speech to patch their plan but that
doesn't mean that their actual
conspiracy was protected by the First
Amendment and to be clear Trump really
can't be punished for saying I think I
won and Pence should block the
certification but he can be charged for
soliciting another person to commit a
crime so it would follow that if Trump
solicited fake electors to submit Forge
certificates with the goal of stopping
the certification then it's fine to
charge him with conspiracy to obstruct
an official proceeding under 18 USC 1512
and the government still has to prove
all the elements of the case for each of
those charges Laurel suggests that a
person cannot be guilty of conspiracy if
their verbal acts solely consists of
political speech protected by the
Constitution which has a kernel of truth
but is also kind of wrong he relies on
Hammersmith vs United States where the
Supreme Court overturned a conviction
against Thomas Hammerschmidt and 12
others who had been handing out
pamphlets urging men not to register for
the select Collective service act now
the ACT authorized the government to
temporarily expand the military through
conscription and the men were convicted
of conspiracy to defraud the United
States in violation what is now 18 USC
371. by the way there are a lot of First
Amendment cases that deal with very very
dubious uh Speech related acts but the
issue in hamishment was whether the men
used trigger agency to encourage people
to evade the draft and the court found
that their conduct did not include
deceit handing out pamphlets was simply
quote open Defiance of the governmental
purpose to enforce a law by urging
persons subject to it to disobey it
which is not fraud in this sense the
case didn't refer to the First Amendment
or discuss whether political speech can
contribute to a criminal conspiracy but
the Hammersmith case referred to a 1910
case called Haas versus Henkel which
might be more analogous to Trump's
situation in that case Moses Hawes and
others were charged with a conspiracy to
the fraud the United States by
attempting to bribe the statistician in
the Department of Agriculture to give
them cotton crop reports before they
were officially released to the public
with a goal of engaging in Market
speculation the statistician was going
to quote falsify one of these official
cotton crop reports of which fact his
associates were to be advised in advance
in Hammerschmidt the men were handing
out political pamphlets urging people to
break the law that was political speech
in Haas the men conspired to secretly
manipulate cotton crop reports including
by falsifying data to allow the
conspirators to engage in Market
speculation now I'm sure Jack Smith is
going to argue that the fact pattern
seems closer to Hawes because it
involves governmental officials using
deceit and trickery to stop the
certification of the election of the
joint session of Congress on January 6.
now to be sure Trump did engage in
political speech but for the most part
Jack Smith's indictment avoided charging
Trump just for making speeches and
posting tweets instead it seems like he
tried to charge speech acts that urge
people including state and federal
officials to break the law by submitting
fraudulent electoral certificates to
Congress and Nara now the Georgia
indictment on the other hand is more
explicitly based on Trump's various
speech acts which may present a problem
and there are other cases that Trump
might rely on to argue that he had no
intent for anyone to commit on lawful
acts for example an NAACP versus
Claiborne Hardware the Supreme Court
ruled that an economic boycott is a form
of constitutionally protected expression
even if violence is threatened as a
means of achieving a group objective the
case involves an economic boycott by
African-Americans against white
merchants operating in Claiborne County
Mississippi and the boycott included
non-violent picketing but there were
also acts of threats of violence and in
1969 white merchants sued the NAACP for
damages and the Court held that the
non-violent elements of the protesters
activities were protected by the First
Amendment the NAACP wasn't liable for
the consequences of their non-violent
activity effectively the court separated
out the non-violent activity that was
protected by the First Amendment and the
potentially violent activity that could
give rise to damages and the Court ruled
the quote for liability to be imposed by
reason of Association alone it is
necessary to establish the group itself
possessed unlawful goals and that the
individual held specific intent to
further these illegal aims persuasion
must be quote directed to inside or
producing imminent Lawless action and
likely to incite or produce such action
in order for it to be considered a crime
now in the aftermath of Claiborne
Hardware Lower Court decisions drew a
line between advocacy and urging illegal
action speech urging illegal action was
unprotected by the first amendment in
some context for example in rice versus
Paladin the fourth circuit ruled that a
publisher of a book a Hitman a technical
manual for independent contractors could
be liable for civilly aiding and
abetting a crime after a contract killer
used the book to murder three people the
Court held that the quote provision of
instructions that Aid and abet another
in the commission of a criminal offense
is not protected by the First Amendment
the First Amendment doesn't bar civil
liability for speech that the plaintiff
can demonstrate was performed with
specific intent the court drew a
distinction between speech that was
advocacy in speech that was aiding and
abetting others by providing the means
to commit the crime the court said that
the Hitman book was not advocacy it was
an instruction manual without relevant
communicative value but the Hitman case
is unusual because Paladin uh for
reasons that I won't go into stipulated
uh that it intended the book to be used
by criminals and would-be criminals and
that it intended and had knowledge that
the book would be used to execute the
crime of murder for hired but for
procedural reasons there was only one
issue before the court and that was
whether the First Amendment acted as a
complete bar to the plaintiff's claims
and of course unlike the Paladin
publisher Trump is not going to
stipulate that he had specific intent
and knowledge that his co-conspirators
intended to commit crimes but the
government is alleging exactly that that
Trump knew his speeches and interviews
and phone calls and memos were in
service of an objective that was against
the law overturning a legitimate
election result so whereas in Claiborne
Hardware the boycotters didn't intend
violence and thus were not liable for
their first amendment protected speech
Trump intended so says the government
for others to break the law on his
behalf and I'm sure Jack Smith will use
Trump's speeches to prove that he had
that specific intent and of course Trump
is going on trial for conspiracy and the
First Circuit Court of Appeals decided a
case called us versus Spock that
involved a letter written by
professionals who were opposed to the
Vietnam War these professionals
including famous pediatrician Benjamin
Spock wrote a letter called a call to
resist illegitimate Authority and some
of them attended protests which
advocated for the burning of draft cards
Spock and three others were convicted of
criminal conspiracy the court reversed
Spock's conviction largely because he
did not have specific intent to further
the illegal aspects of the letter the
court observed the quote it is true that
he was one of the drafters of the call
but this does not evidence the necessary
intent to adhere to its illegal aspects
nor does his admission to a government
agent that he was willing to do anything
asked for further opposition to the war
specific intent is not established by
such a generalization whatever the
reason the fact is that his speech was
limited to condemnation of the war and
the draft and lacked any words or
content of counseling the jury could not
find prescribed advocacy from the mere
fact which he freely admitted that he
hoped the frequent stating of his views
might give young men courage to take
active steps in draft resistance this is
a natural consequence of vigorous
so this looks like a better argument for
Trump that he like Dr Spock repeatedly
stated his views publicly in the hopes
that it might give courage to people to
take some action but they lacked
knowledge of illegal efforts on his
behalf and the intent to see them
succeed now Smith's indictment says that
Trump's activities included both legal
and illegal means of achieving a second
term despite losing the election but
Trump will argue that he never tried to
further any illegal activities what this
all boils down to is that the government
has proved that Trump had the men's Raya
the necessary mental state to commit the
crimes he's accused of now this sounds
complicated but it's actually how all of
criminal law works the exact same act
can be perfectly innocent or a crime
based on the mental state of the
defendant now as you can probably tell
Trump and his co-defendants are going to
need a good lawyer but if you need a
great lawyer my firm the eagle team can
help if your loved one has suffered from
cancer has suffered an injury or death
in the family or were involved in a car
crash we can represent you or help find
you the right attorney just click on the
link in the description for free
consultation with my team because you
don't just need a legal team you need
the eagle team the link is below now
back to the First Amendment now in
addition you might have heard that the
special prosecutor moved for a gag order
to stop Trump from communicating about
the case now that's not really true but
the government did file a motion for a
protective order on Friday August 4th
now a motion for a protective order is
an extremely routine motion to make
especially in a case that involves
sensitive material so that in particular
is not unusual but what happened is that
the government filed its motion after
Trump went on Truth social and posted if
you go after me I'm coming after you and
in the motion prosecutors cited the
truth social post as evidence that
protective order was necessary the
government's theory is that Trump has a
history of sharing information that the
public shouldn't have now balancing a
criminal defendant's right to free
speech with a need to keep order in
trial and in court while also balancing
the ability of that person to run for
president of the United States is well
tricky or as Ken white more colorfully
put it basically it's a nightmare Law
School exam by a sadistic drunk law
professor and the government said that
the order was necessary to quote allow
the government to begin producing that
Discovery much of which includes
sensitive and confidential information
the government respectfully moves the
court for entry of the attached proposed
protective order governing the
disclosure of Discovery now mind you
when you have a criminal defendant that
defendant is entitled to see the
evidence that's going to be presented
against them this process of turning
over information is called Discovery and
the point of Discovery in the criminal
context is to inform the defendant about
the evidence that's going to be used
against them and as you might imagine
there's a lot of sensitive information
here quote materials containing
personally identifying information as
identified in federal rule of criminal
procedure 49.1 rule six materials
including subpoena returns witness
testimony and related exhibits presented
to the grand jury materials obtained
through sealed search warrants and 2703
D orders sealed orders obtained by the
government's filter team related to the
case recordings transcripts interview
reports and related exhibits of witness
interviews and sensitive materials
obtained from other governmental
entities and the idea is that the
protective order quote allows the
defendant prompt and effective use of
Discovery materials in connection with
his defense including by showing
Discovery materials to Witnesses who
also agree to abide by the order's terms
the idea is that the discovery would be
given to Trump but he wouldn't be
allowed to share it with the public
prosecutors said quote such a
restriction is particularly important in
this case because the defendant has
previously issued public statements on
social media regarding Witnesses judges
attorneys and others associated with
legal matters pending against him and
not surprisingly has evidence the
government referenced Trump's truth
social screen they said quote if the
defendant were to begin issuing public
posts using details or for example grand
jury transcripts obtained in Discovery
here it could have a harmful chilling
effect on Witnesses or adversely affect
the fair administration of justice in
this case in response Trump's lawyer
said quote the government does not
explain how a post on a different topic
which does not include or describes
sensitive information suggests president
Trump might disseminate such information
in the future and Trump's lawyer said
that the need to protect that
information does not require a blanket
gag order over all documents produced by
the government and their response brief
accused Jack Smith's prosecutors of
leaking evidence stating that the doj
posed quote the greater risk of improper
disclosure now judge chuckin had a
hearing to resolve the party's inability
to agree on the scope of the protective
order and after she issued the
protective order Trump said that he
might or might not comply with the
judge's order
[Music]
so what were they arguing about well the
first big issue was whether all
information the government obtained
during the investigation should be
covered by the protective order as the
prosecution wanted but the judge was not
persuaded that the government proved
that all information gathered in the
case should fall under the protective
order and the judge ruled that the
government can designate certain
materials as sensitive but not all of
them but notably the judge agreed with
the government that every single person
interviewed by prosecutors is a
potential witness and is therefore
sensitive information the judge
suggested that Trump might release
evidence about Mike Pence in order to
denigrate him as a witness but the
defendant's desire to respond to
political opponents has to yield there
are limits this is a criminal case the
need for this case to proceed in a
normal order means there are going to be
limits on the defendant's speech the
judge was also concerned that Witnesses
couldn't be intimidated by quote members
of the public also who are not bound by
the conditions of the release now Laurel
pleaded with the judge to consider that
Trump needed to be able to discuss
everything listed in paragraph 8 on the
debate stage uh but judge checking said
that the political campaign would have
no bearing on any of her decisions in
the case she chided lauro for quote
inflating what your client needs to
defend himself and what he wants to do
politically your client's defense has to
happen in the courtroom not on the
internet to the extent your client wants
to make statements on the internet he
has to yield to witness security Now the
second major issue was whether Trump
would be allowed to see all the
discovery in the case and what he'd be
allowed to do with that material and
here judge chuckin fashioned a
compromise Trump is allowed to review
sensitive information without his legal
team present in the room but the team
must be present to retrieve the
materials as soon as Trump exits the
room if Trump takes notes his lawyers
must review them to assure that he did
not write down sensitive personal
information Trump is also not permitted
to have an electronic device with him
that would allow him to take a picture
or photocopy the document quote if the
defendant takes notes regarding
sensitive materials defense counsel must
inspect those nodes to ensure that the
defendant has not copied down personally
identifying information now this puts a
lot of pressure on the lawyers to make
sure that their client is complying with
the order now with normal clients this
isn't such a big deal but this is
obviously Donald Trump that we're
dealing with here and things are getting
especially interesting because in the
wake of the protective order Trump has
arguably directed speech at a witness
and Georgia saying quote I am reading
reports that failed former lieutenant
governor of Georgia Jeff Duncan will be
testifying before the Fulton County
grand jury he shouldn't and then goes on
even further now that's not great now
while some commentators have argued that
this constitutes witness tampering the
Georgia witness tampering statute is
mainly concerned with threats and bribes
and likely doesn't apply here and judge
chicken's protective order prevents
Trump and his legal team from disclosing
sensitive matters revealed in Discovery
but it doesn't really touch on
statements like that Trump's condition
of his release do actually bar him from
harassing or intimidating Witnesses but
that would likely only apply to
Witnesses in his DC case so given all
the gray areas here I wouldn't expect
that any of the judges here to be the
first to rush to jail Trump or hold
Trump in contempt over his social media
posts but right after the Duncan related
post he also targeted judge chuckin by
commenting on her past in court
statements which is at the very least
likely to piss off the judge though In
fairness it's not a great statement from
the judge it's a gratuitous reference to
Trump who wasn't on trial in that
particular January 6 case but I'm sure
that these are only just the first in a
long string of free speech hypotheticals
that would drive any student in con law
too insane or a YouTube lawyer as the
case may be but all this just makes my
brain hurt so I think I'll just sit back
and enjoy a delicious meal delivered
straight to my door which I can get with
today's sponsor Factor because Factor
makes meeting your nutrition goals
easier than ever by delivering fresh
never Frozen dietitian approved meals
right to your doorstep and the meals are
completely ready to eat you can
eliminate hours it would take to shop to
meal prep and to cook so you can spend
your time doing the things that you
actually want to do factory meals arrive
pre-prepared and ready to eat in just
two minutes at the same time that I
could even think about going to the
grocery store my Factor meal is already
done sometimes I just want a good
healthy meal without having to cook and
it's surprisingly affordable factors
team of gourmet chefs creates each meal
using only ingredients with Integrity to
help you feel your best all day long and
they really are extremely delicious like
bruschetta shrimp risotto Green Goddess
chicken grilled Steakhouse filet mignon
ready in just two minutes and their
menus are updated weekly with 34
different options you can choose your
favorite meal or let Factor craft your
order based on your taste preferences
and meal history so give fact or try by
heading to factor75.com and use the code
legal eagle 50 to get 50 off your first
Factor box or just click on the link
that's on screen right now or down in
the description and use the code legal
eagle 50 to get 50 off your first Factor
box all you have to do is click on the
link that's down below after that click
on this link over here for more legal
eagle or I'll see you in court